i've had this conversation with lots of
people over the years um where they'll
say
look there's no movie that's going to
dislodge my understanding of god i'm
sorry like if i watch this movie i'm not
all of a sudden going to reject god
can fictional stories really have an
impact on people
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness what's up
everybody welcome to led live we just
like to say thank you to our sponsors
especially our patreon donors if you
want to support this channel you can
become a patreon donor and get a lot of
behind the scenes stuff and we can't do
this show without you so we thank you
today we're gonna get into um a
presentation about can fictional stories
have an influence on people do you guys
think that fiction can actually because
people tell us all the time i know the
difference in fiction and reality you
guys are nuts and if you can't tell the
difference in fiction and reality then
there's something wrong with you like
but does fiction
have an influence or an impact on people
do they get scared when they're watching
scary movies
crying when there's an emotional scene
yeah
that's a fictional thing that's
impacting you in some way i think if you
just look on the internet or even just
on youtube you'll see people that are
like dude this is why this movie changed
my life we the matrix is not real sorry
people right in case you thought that
was real but there's tons of people that
have been affected by that yeah and i
think people are pretty honest with
themselves when it's
you know something like that like the
matrix was awesome it changed my life i
don't well we're going to show you
what's in the matrix no
you guys are crazy it doesn't affect me
wait you just said it did yeah even the
language
saying stuff like the matrix or you're
red pilled or blue pilled yeah that
would have been meaningless before the
film i think what it really boils down
to for people at the end of the day is
what they're saying when they say it
doesn't affect me is
it's not going to change my belief
system
but that's really what they they mean
do you think it can though sure i think
it can yeah i think
i think we've seen it all through
history i think people are getting more
open about it like disney said we're not
going to get involved in the political
issue about the lgbt stuff but we will
change and shape minds through our art
we would like to thank all of you who
support this ministry through your
donations and by buying merch from
lightwear.shop
we cannot do this without you and if you
send in your pictures we will put you on
the show
do you guys know what it means to
challenge a book
i've heard that i guess do you know what
that means i've heard it too so this is
groups of people um there's a lot of
reading that's suggested to kids or
whatever in school and there's actually
a group that you can challenge the books
and have the books removed
and i heard on the radio the other day
that they said that normally there's uh
i can't remember what the percentage was
but it was like it wasn't very many it
was like x amount of of books are
are um challenged and this last year
it's like quadrupled or more it was just
like yeah it's like all of a sudden now
we have all this material that people
are like society should not be reading
this remember some of the titles
i don't but i i remember um the golden
compass and those books were one that
was challenged the giver i think it was
one so the golden compass was in there
that's interesting why i wonder because
like demons are your friend or is it
something else i mean you gotta wonder
uh yeah i just i i think that those kind
of stories there's there's groups of
parents and things that are like hey we
need to we need to not let our children
be exposed to these things because it
will have some negative impact so i
think that's kind of fascinating the
giver is very gnostic story like that
and yeah it was banned i think that was
one that came through our homeschooling
curriculum maybe my wife always goes
through all the books and she's like you
know what's in here and this is what
we're not going to read
so she does it at home so i think
everybody censors based on
you know
yeah what's coming your way right you
know if it doesn't happen if it's just
fiction don't have an impact why would
you say well we can't read this because
it's kind of controversial or whatever
here's a you guys know this book yep the
boy who cried wolf
why do parents read this to their kids
i actually don't know what it is
aesop's fable um i don't know the little
boy who cried dude i just knew the table
i knew the same but i didn't know it
actually came from a book i just asked
high school students if they'd heard of
this and they were all like altered i'm
sorry
i was surprised that it's still being
told to this day because it is such an
old story but this is what it says this
tale concerns a shepherd boy who
repeatedly tricks nearby villagers into
thinking a wolf is attacking his flock
when a wolf actually does appear the
villagers do not believe the boy's cries
for help and the flock is destroyed the
moral of the story the moral of the
story is that liars will not be rewarded
even if they tell the truth no one
believes them
so
the story is basically he's a shepherd
boy he's like wolf and all the people
come and he's like
i got you as a joke he did it a couple
of times well when a wolf really came
he's like woah woof woof and that's that
boy again we're not gonna ignore him
probably his best performance yeah is
this really where that saying came from
yeah yeah yeah aesop's fable it's like
an old old story i i'm gonna have to
have a conversation with my parents it's
like teaching you like don't don't you
know like this
today like pull the fire alarm or
something that's a joke then you won't
believe it when it's real oh i remember
the saying very well but i didn't know
it came from a book yeah so
this story is told to kids because it
has a moral a lesson
you're hoping that the kid is going to
learn something from this fictional
story that's why it's being read to
teach your kids something
the lore acts by dr seuss dr seuss lorax
warns of the dangers of pollution and
industrialization in a world where the
beautiful truffle trough
trees are all being cut down to make way
for the more things for for more things
progressive or progress versus the
environment's natural beauty continues
to be a challenge making this story
eternally relevant and this little clip
from the book says
unless someone like you
cares a whole awful lot
nothing is going to get better no it's
not so
i i think it's interesting um
i mean
art is meant to affect someone right
like nobody's gonna create this and hope
that um you know i'm gonna put this out
and nobody's gonna be nobody's gonna
think twice about it i think you have to
recognize even kids books the ones that
have made it through the test of time
things like the giving tree or something
like that i mean people have literally
said this book changed my perceptive on
all sorts of things political cartoons
yeah and the tree doesn't have the
ability to talk to the boy you know and
it's like that's that's that's
fascinating to me that people would deny
that that these things don't affect you
i would hope
everyone would agree that fiction can
affect you in the case of the boy who
cried wolf you can apply that moral to
your life and be affected in a positive
way
my question is do we have a choice
whether the effect can happen or not
because you can choose not to apply that
lesson to your to your life and then go
on lying
so is there an element of of um not
having a choice of a subconscious level
i think
things that you normally wouldn't agree
with can be manipulated in a way to make
you like uh accept it so
like uh what we're gonna talk about here
in a second but
say they present to you an idea that you
normally wouldn't accept but they they
got this whole emotional story wrapped
around the music is all emotional and
you're like yeah
so say it's like a lesbian couple who
they're getting married but their family
doesn't accept them and they're feeling
shunned and all these things it's
emotional they're crying they're hugging
each other we just want to love each
other we just want to be in a marriage
or something and it's pulling your heart
strings and now it's like yeah identify
with that why won't they just let them
well they accept them love is love and
all this stuff
whereas normally you might just be like
no i don't agree with homosexuality it's
against the bible you know it's not
natural or whatever it can be hard to
know and i think you were kind of
hitting on it just a second ago
you know you take for example a movie
like the noah movie what's the point of
that movie
you may not know unless the person who
wrote it directed it produced it told
you
right you don't know what their
intention is it just to make something
cool or is it to actually influence a
person's perception and opinion
so you asked darren aronofsky what is
the noah movie about is this about the
bible nope nope nothing to do with the
bible what is it it's about global
warming
it's just using that story as the
delivery vehicle for global warming and
james mctiernan basically said the same
thing
you can look this up on his imdb profile
he's like you know
he loves these
doing this because he can he says you
can use this filmmaking as a trojan
horse whoa
to
slip in you know a political agenda
in your film yeah
and correct me from wrong but he didn't
even go to the bible for that story he
went to a gnostic
he co-wrote a novel with somebody else
in the french language
they titled it noah
and they used elements of the biblical
story
to package it
but it's not it's not the same story i
don't wonder if they wanted to get
christians
sure i mean who do you want to influence
yeah right i think another thing to kind
of consider here is
um
we're looking at the overall effect and
and i think somebody walking away from a
book is saying well i'm not really
influenced by that or i can pick and
choose between the good um how do you
even judge that because
it's not like on the flip side of that
your your child that comes
into church and you read them a bible
story it's not gonna be like wow i
totally understand everything it's like
these little incremental pieces of
information spread over time that's
going to give them this world view well
i think the same thing applies here you
may not be directly noticeably
influenced right off the bat but i
guarantee you time and time and time and
time time over a lifetime is going to
have an influence
one way is you know if it's a series
uh did you buy the sequel
i mean think about it if the first one
didn't mean anything to you didn't
affect you at all why would you buy the
next one
but there are multiple book series you
know that people get involved in harry
potter books right twilight series
all those kind of things and we did a
video witchcraft on the rise in america
and there's multiple people that were
like they got interested in witchcraft
because of they read harry potter
growing up yeah i just saw a testimony
of a lady who um grew up in a christian
home she was at a friend's house
sleepover and they watched charmed she
was in high school and she all of a
sudden was like that looks exciting and
she she said she didn't even remember
the end of the of the movie how the
witchcraft basically turned against the
the four uh teenagers and she said all
she saw was the glamorized v this is the
power
that was fascinating but she said
literally it was all just because of
sleepover and they watched it and she
said oh wow that looks exciting and it
wasn't that simple that got her into it
and that movie
got me too and yeah there was one girl
that kind of took it to the extreme but
see that's
one girl
it's like christianity they're gonna say
oh christians you know they go out and
they bomb abortion clinics and stuff
maybe one has
i'm not gonna deny that but that's not
what christina so that movie actually
set out of the four girls
one took it too far went too dark with
it but the others we did it for positive
white white magic and these things so
it really had a more powerful it was
saying that the majority it's not going
to happen to the majority of this is a
good thing so what do you think about
this going back to choice we make
decisions with our conscience right well
what about like but it's influenced by
our subconscious so what if you're
watching something do you really have a
choice if you didn't even pick it up
consciously it went into your
subconscious then you make a decision
down the line that you never thought you
would
keith brought this up um about the noah
movie and i had watched it a few times
and never
saw that it's uh evolution in there yeah
instead of the creation story it's the
evolution story and i think because my
god was so down
i was just like oh yeah this is creation
because it's noah and i didn't click oh
no and if we watch it back maybe we'll
put the clip in there it's actually
evolution
let me tell you a story
in the beginning
there was nothing
but the breath of the creator flooded
against the face of the void whispering
let there be light
and light was
and it was good
the first day
and then the formless light
began to take on substance and shape
second day
and our world was born
a beautiful fragile home
and a great warming life nurtured its
days
and the lesser light ruled the nights
and there was evening
and morning
another day
and the waters of the world gathered
together
and in their midst
emerged dry land
another day passed
and the ground put forth the growing
things
a thick blanket of green stretching
across all creation
the waters too
teamed with life
great creatures of the deep that are no
more
vast multitudes of fish some of which
may still swim beneath these seas
and soon
the sky was streaming with birds
and that was evening
and there was morning
fifth day
now the whole world was full of living
beings everything that creeps everything
that crawls and every beast that walks
upon the ground and it was good it was
all good
there was light and air and water and
soil all clean and unspoiled the plants
and fish the fowl and beast each after
their own kind all part of the greater
whole all in their place and all was in
balance
was paradise
the jewel and the creator's path
and the creator made man
by his sideboard
father and mother of us all
he gave them a choice
[Music]
follow the temptation of darkness
or hold on to the blessing of light
and so
with those different elements being put
in your mind from different sources not
just that movie
um maybe that could be how someone
traced how they came up with the their
now newfound belief of evolution that
they never thought they would have right
yeah it's a lot of truth a little bit of
error how deception works
so jesus knew the power of fiction and
matthew 13 34 says all these things
jesus spoke to the multitude in parables
which is a fictitious story and without
a parable did not he did not speak to
them so literally all the sermons that
jesus spoke was a parable and if you
took his story as literal then you
walked away thinking oh yeah this guy
was on a hill and he was teaching us how
to plant crops and build our house on a
rock and all these things they missed
the whole lesson i would disagree with
you a little bit okay i think we
actually have evidence to believe that
most if not all the stories jesus told
were actually true
and so that when he was telling parables
yes he's telling parables
but the one exception i can think of is
the story of the rich man and lazarus
right okay well that's like it's you can
tell it's not literal we're building a
house on the rock and sowing seeds but a
lot of those things
you know
if you if you read
um
carefully and if you read commentaries
you can actually gain insight that you
know jesus
was
looking across you know the way and
watching somebody do that and
okay you know what i mean so it's like
yeah these are object lessons so it's
not like they're they're just totally
made up for stories exactly the other
thing that you'll learn in in some
classes is that
um a lot of the stories that jesus told
were were variations
um
on
cultural stories
those stories could have been made up
but jesus was like repackaging them in
their
uh current
place and time but using real events
that happen so
it could be that the good samaritan
story was just like
it just okay you just just made that up
right or it could be that that story
actually happened it doesn't lose
it happened i saw in the chosen
not because of the chosen but
but but likely it happened yeah and so
in in that sense it's not like jesus is
just trying to promote or
peddle
fiction
it's that you know he's telling it as a
parable because it's it's a he's telling
a story and there's nothing inherently
wrong with the story exactly
he's just using that as the vehicle to
package the information the power of
storytelling the power of storytelling
so that just just a slight you know
slight well well that's a variation some
pack that just a tiny little bit the
reason why it's impactful is because it
puts it in your relevant space and your
your your language that you understand
because you have had that experience
and that's why i think you know we are
identifying with these things that we
like whether it be a book or a story or
whatever like this is because we're
somehow placing ourselves in that in
their shoes he spoke a lot about farming
because most of the culture was farmers
so he's using their language to
basically frame oh yeah now i understand
what you're saying you know kind of a
thing we do it all the time when we say
like um
you know there's this law that does this
and that and you'd be like it'd be the
same as if you did this to somebody we
have to build a story to make people
identify because that law or whatever
you're explaining might not really click
until you're like okay think about
you're in this situation dude this is
so how does satan counterfeit
jesus parables
he's going to do the same thing i know
the power of fiction or the power of
storytelling in general
satan is going to use the most
powerful
storytelling device there is the media
this isn't even as far as i know this
isn't a christian website but it says
it's a parental website and it says 15
movies that help kids do the right thing
so movies are helping kids to do the
right thing in the article it says
we parents work hard to teach our kids
to do the right thing
doing the right thing conversations are
not always easy to have which is why we
recommend this unexpected strategy to
help
watch a movie
here's a list of films with powerful
stories of kids championing everything
from gender equality to the ethical
treatment of animals so instead of
trying to perfect the art of
communication
they're like now let's just sit and
watch this so i saw this really funny
video clip where this guy was breaking
down all these gender issues that are
now put in kids stories and blues clues
was one of the ones that he popped up
and do do you remember the whole like uh
transgender parade on blue clues and the
guy i mean he was hilarious he was all
so wait a minute like a few years ago
the guy that played blues clues would
lose his pen
and the whole thing was about him trying
to figure out where the pen went how did
we get to discussing your sexual
preference to a tiny two-year-old like i
just mind-boggling where we've got to
but yeah they're sliding these things in
everything the level of trust you know
instead of you communicating with your
child okay let me just put you in front
of this screen and whatever messages is
there there you go that's the
conversation have you any of you watched
blue's clues recently before okay yeah
you've seen it though you've seen it
yeah i mean it's like so slow
that like of course you as a parent are
gonna get up and go do something so yeah
at this stage you're not
sitting there paying attention to what
your kid is soaking up and he's like do
you see a clue and they're like okay i'm
gonna do the dishes and you come back
like oh my goodness what happened that
derailed but
you know and i i see what kendy's saying
for sure you should be having these
these conversations but it's not bad to
learn a lesson from a movie or a book
but
this is saying that that this has the
power to do it the movie has the power
to teach your kids something yeah to me
here the whole thing centers on this
doing the right thing yeah what's the
right thing this is yeah exactly what is
the right thing
that's what you have to define first of
all yeah and then now this becomes
the moral compass
yeah right as opposed to how society is
deeming that's right or that's wrong
because right now in certain parts of
our society you cannot say things about
certain gender issues i mean and so is
it that society's right or
that's relativism where's your rule
relativism is always dangerous because
it always changes over time yeah
so here's a secular site saying that
movies help teach kids a lesson screen
ran another secular site says 10
children's movies that have terrible
moral lessons so this is not a christian
but they see it that some movies have
terrible lessons
cinema shapes young minds that just says
volumes right there cinema shapes young
minds
but what if these beloved films actually
have awful messages look no further than
a christmas story or home alone home
alone
he wasn't left by so
i don't know i mean that was an
accidental thing but they go on to say
they're talking about moana in this
little clip here it says
one of the biggest moments in the film
is when moana defies the commands of her
parents and sets out on the ocean alone
though an inspiring moment it also seems
to suggest if there is something a kid
really wants to do they don't have to
listen to their parents at all what
would they say about turning red i know
i was just about ready to say that
because they brought up the concept when
she's like you know we we we think that
we should honor our parents no i don't
need to do that you know what yeah and
she's like shaking her butt at her mom
saying take that take that knocks her
mom out
i don't know if you've come across this
but recently i have and that there is a
high proportion of
disney films that actually have at least
one missing parent oh yeah all the time
all the time i don't know what that is i
don't understand what that's about it's
like reinforcing it like in a subtle way
yeah need
parents i i guess we couldn't quite make
a large connection to that but it is a
question of we got a lot of single
parents today in our society but this
has been going on for a long time
cinderella there's always a step there
and all that stuff you think that for a
long time the population's been
programmed so you combine it with ideas
like this and it's like it's like one
step closer to that yeah there's many
different factors yeah i've definitely
noticed that i've been trying to figure
out what that's about no it's all disney
it's all their fault well there's the
intro we
we did a show on witchcraft and we
watched the upside down magic or
whatever in the the opening scene it's
like panning by a house and goes into
the girl's window and she's saying
uh you know something about me and my
mom and my dad passed away or whatever
it's like it's always like let's set the
scene i have one parent
so children imitate fiction this is no
oh yeah this is no nothing to hide i
mean this is
clearly they have parties and everything
i like that scotty said his son
went to a birthday party that was
superhero based and he's like it was a
scary guy he calls them the scary guys
he doesn't know all their names is that
they really are this guy's got claws
well i just think it's very interesting
too when you see young children in like
deadpool outfits yeah whatever and
you're like did you watch deadpool kids
you shouldn't have right it's actually a
video circulating it's kind of old but
it's a kid i think he was dressed up as
batman stands at the top of a stair
flight of stairs and jumps oh no and the
dad was recording him or something right
the dad was recording him and the dad's
like okay don't do that again
yeah i don't think you should never do
that again
i thought you was gonna walk down the
top steps that was crazy
don't let that cake boost your head up
no more yeah but we're gonna go watch
the movie it's like
conflicting ideas for you this one's
gonna go viral sun
yeah so we know that your kids are
imitating this stuff they watch the
movies and they're outside afterwards
like doing you know lightsaber wars and
stuff they're seeing they're literally
acting out dressing up doing exactly
what they see in the movies yeah this is
actually better this is probably old
photo because now they'll probably all
be dressed as villains since there's an
uptick in their villagers
the good guys supposedly guys which is
superheroes i mean now you might have
some of those boys dressing as the
princesses right yeah
okay
okay that's true
so
if there this is a fake thing that i put
together but if there was a comic book
character named super nazi would you
read it to your kids
yeah they could learn some lessons from
that i'm sure there's a lot of good
lessons on this totally joking please
okay
it's fiction right
it's fiction it doesn't have an
influence it doesn't impact me i know
the difference in fiction and reality
let's read super nazi to our kids
this this probably is is truer to what
happened back then because
i know that adolf hitler was very
keen on um the arts
so
that was one of the ways that he
actually really got his entire
population to think that jews were
terrible people is he he changed the
cinema he changed the advertisements he
changed the art the books everything
like this he literally targeted a lot of
that type of stuff and it had an impact
on his society yeah i mean i i thought i
had a slide in here we can add it in but
there's uh all kinds of propaganda of
him like holding children and with a
dove over his head while he's holding
this big staff and stuff and like making
him look like a messiah figure and we
see that even today i mean you see
you'll see obama on the cover of time
magazine with this big halo around him
or something and it's like that's
telling the viewer something without
even words it's like oh yeah he's uh
he's gonna help save
our country
would an atheist be offended if i read
these fictional comic books to his
children i was babysitting if i'm
babysitting atheist kid and i'm reading
these christian crusader comic books do
you think he'd be okay with that
yeah i'm sure you'd you know
probably not yeah no they'd probably
definitely be like why are you shoving
your beliefs down my kid's throat you
know you're i'm like it's fiction bro
it's just a comic book
but they would have why are they afraid
of that exposure you know if your kid is
such an adult and you believe that they
can make the decision though you believe
they can tell the difference between
fiction and non-fiction what's the
problem with exposing them to this right
is your kid watching something that's
glorifying witchcraft well that's that's
a religion wick is a religion
along that line of
thought why do we have ratings
on
films and tv shows yeah that adultery on
camera that's fiction anyway it's fake
yeah the murder scene was fake just go
ahead why does the blood have to be blue
instead of red yeah before they get the
lower rating yeah
we wouldn't have a cancel culture if
fiction didn't
have an influence so i'll step i'll step
out on limb here and kind of go uh where
i think this is actually going this is
much bigger i think what what happens in
a in a in a biblical world view is
satan is working with groups of people
that are basically inching
laws and things closer to what he wants
down the road so they may in the
beginning think that they're fighting
for x initiative or whatever but what
that's doing is really setting people up
to be able to come into your space and
say we don't like what you what you said
there and let's take it away so freedom
of speech is being eroded away for the
specific reason of down the road the
devil's got a plan for that so i think
people get emotionally invested in those
kind of like initiatives but i think the
bigger picture is that it's really it's
really taking away our freedom yeah
divide and conquer i agree
there again there wouldn't be a demand
for representation if fiction didn't
have influence why would you say
we want 50 representation in lgbtq
community
five percent maybe six percent of the
population
they're demanding right now they're at
20 and that's what they want but they're
demanding we want 50 of programming to
have some kind of representation of our
community
but if it doesn't have an influence why
fight for something like that
this is a lgbtq
website called seat up
and they actually said what is media
it says media representation is a
powerful tool for shaping cultural
understanding of people places and
groups
of people like those identifying as
lesbian gay bisexual transgender queer
or another non-gender conforming
identity so they this is not us this is
not some
christian zealot saying this they're
saying that media representation is a
powerful tool to shape cultural
understanding
so fictional
stories like shows and movies and things
like that you can't you can't have it
both ways it either does or doesn't they
go on to say the media we are most often
exposed to in modern western life are
television including streaming services
and social media but movies plays
musicals magazines newspapers and even
radio are still influential messengers
of the cultural zeitgeist so this is why
they want representation because
they want the world to know something
about their lifestyle and to accept it
and embrace it i mean joe rogan i think
is a prime example of you know a podcast
having a huge influence on people and
you know it's like
all you do is talking about stuff right
yeah he's just interviewing somebody and
he may or may not agree what that person
says but he wants to have an interesting
talk
is there anything wrong with this
picture here
well there's bail and baby's getting
offered to him
but i don't super bad okay superville i
didn't read the name of the book i was
like there's an idol in it so if jesus
is reading to children
this book
is that something that we think jesus
would do no no why not
this is about a false idol
but it's a superhero
which is a is a
a god
okay so do we see that in the culture
today do we see
parents or even christian communities
reading
about false gods to their children
yeah i mean if if you just do a little
bit of digging you can see i mean any of
your favorite superheroes i mean just
get on the internet and ask a couple
questions what's the history of superman
what's the history of flash
and just read a little bit about where
those characters actually come from or
who they're modeled after and it doesn't
take a rocket scientist to see that
these are just repackaged greek and
roman gods so they take greek and roman
gods repackage them put them in a
fictitious story
and now it's acceptable yeah is it yeah
and i kind of said this in a previous
show it wasn't taken well but i mean it
is what it is and that when we look at
the culture where we are right now in
the united states and the certain
freedoms that we enjoy
it can't just be limited to christianity
or christians it's everyone everyone's
enjoying these freedoms but where we do
have power of of choice and what comes
in and out of our lives in our homes
so sure there's freedom to have comic
books like this or for there to be um
you know superheroes from mystic gods
sure yeah
but doesn't need to be in our homes and
that's a question that we need to ask i
don't believe like you said i don't
believe that we need to and my
perspective is i think these things are
evil but i don't think we need to police
somebody making this
i think we need to have a voice that
says you know these things are not a
biblical worldview but i don't think
controlling it or saying because i
believe in the bible and that's a false
god you have you do not have the ability
to make that i i think that that's
because would it work if it was flipped
and they were trying to cancel the
purpose is
to inform because there's so many people
that just think
it's normal yeah just because it's
normal in your society or cultural
doesn't make it right and that's why we
get attacked with all the time you guys
are attacking somebody's culture they
worship dragons over there in japan so
you you can't say anything wrong about
it because it's cultural the bible says
the world is worships the dragon and the
serpent and you look all over the world
and you see dragon worship serpent
worship
and yet it's a cultural thing and that's
a good point is it cultural or is it
just the norm right now yeah and i'd
advise you to check out um
we had a chinese pastor on our show
remember his name
dr wang dr wang we'll put the link
somewhere in the video but um i
um
encourage you to watch that because he
delves into answering that question are
certain things actually cultural or do
they become that way over time
so as something becomes kind of
normalized it becomes cultural so
america
you know coca-cola culture whatever pop
culture you know we have pop culture so
superheroes is kind of our pop culture
literally false gods
are our culture
and you can't say anything wrong with it
because no that's just america's culture
man they're into that
yeah
culture is is
is again like you're saying it's it's
relative it can change over time
there's probably a reason none of us
live in a society or a culture of
cannibals right
i mean we would be lunch one day yeah
and uh
you know it might be normal to those
people growing up but that doesn't make
it right right morality is different
than cultural norms yeah
we normally don't eat people but
you know in your case we'll make an
exception in rome actually have a
restaurant i think it's in france or
something like this where you can
actually go and eat a human body no i'm
dead
it's actually disgusting
you can you know like you sign on your
driver's license how you can say i want
to donate my
things yeah you can go through a medical
test that says i want to donate my body
to this restaurant
and i think they buy the body i can't
remember what it is but it's just
mind-boggling that she would who who
would even think of something like that
first off and then secondly who goes to
the restaurant wanting to try some human
mind-boggling yes society will change
and if that became the social norm
i guarantee it's probably really
expensive and it's a bunch of people who
like i've done everything there is to do
what i was going to do eat a body sure
let's try it right that's one thing i
haven't done
so here's some examples of yeah quickly
like i'm thinking of people who might be
in that culture so you brought up japan
and the dragons like that's my culture i
don't want to leave it but when we enter
into christianity we enter into
christian culture and biblical culture
and if anything within your culture is
in conflict with the biblical culture
a decision needs to be made right that's
right very good point
so the heroes in these comics are most
often times dark i mean look at this
strike force with a flaming pentagram
you got hell storm with
pentagram on his chest he looks like
it's straight up demon you got satana
the
the devil's daughter these are real oh
yeah these are marvel comics so i have a
question i wonder
if have you ever looked up and seen
does marvel make like a jesus comic
i just got shown something the other day
while we were at that camp meeting
actually
um yeah there's a marvel comic right now
that shows jesus in it and they said
that
all the miracles he did were actually
just super powers and stuff
accurate but but i mean like okay so
let's be fair if they're putting stuff
out that's like oh this is just a
fictional character what would be the
problem then of saying you know what
there's probably a demographic of people
that would read a jesus one and let's do
that i mean if that's what you're after
but they
don't that's an interesting
thought though to think that they're
saying well it's science because you
remember what they say in thor yeah you
know where you come from it's science
where i come from it's magic yeah wow
because because who does that ultimately
rob the the attribution to
it takes it away from god and then it's
in our power of our hands magic is truly
just the simple counterfeit of giving
that glory to god and saying god i
didn't make this happen god made it
happen and satan's like no no you just
have the right elements the right potion
the right mixture you can do it i don't
know i think i'm actually kind of happy
that they don't have this in their
series you wouldn't go to auto mechanic
shop for your medication just because
it's available there
so maybe but but i'm just saying i'm
just saying that speaks to the element
of if they don't have that is there some
sort of agenda like why do you put out
all this satan stuff but you on the
other side of the hand you're not going
to put out something that's like leading
people to jesus you know in america
everybody brings up captain america like
you've got no problem making this kind
of stuff but i've seen some dark stuff
on captain america right now i'm sure
i'm sure
so they don't hide that these
good guys are the our gods i mean the
lost gods you know look how they win i
know did they even just repackage the
god squad with the pentagram on his
chest still the trinity but the trinity
dc and marvel both have their own
trinity i can't remember what the marvel
version of the trinity is but you can
look it up like type in marvel trinity
and you're going to find there's a three
i bet you it's
hulk and
it might be i don't know actually and
cbr which is christian or not christian
not christian at all it's comic book
resources or something like that dot com
holy books 15 divine comics
uh 15 divine comic book stories
and in it they say superman batman
martian manhunter green lantern wonder
woman and aquaman all of whom
collectively stood in for the classic
gods
they most resemble another reason is
that it had some fantastic storylines
some of which are rooted fundamentally
in classical mythology
in issues six through eight for example
the team fights actual angels that
threaten the earth
one angel zuriel zuriel would be a good
angel because it has the l in the end
even fight side by side with the team so
a good angel fighting with these false
gods
fighting actual angels that threaten the
earth
okay so don't just skip over that
explain the l for someone who doesn't
know so if the name biblical name ends
in l it means of god so zariel might
mean like wisdom of god or like
dan yell
is god's my judge i think
and then it goes on to say
but more importantly as gods characters
like wonder woman for example are shown
as being stronger and wiser while
superman is at the peak of his power
batman meanwhile plays the ultimate god
of what
the underworld batman is the god of the
underworld and he's actually called
the son of the demon and things like
that some of these comic books aren't
even hiding who they are
the writer of dc that we did in the
replacement god series didn't he say
batman is hades
superman is zeus batman is hades aquaman
is neptune flashes hermes and then that
guy said batman is based off of a demon
and then there's these comics that say
son of the demon and things like that
the ancient gods of greece and rome and
egypt still exist
only today they wear spandex in case
superman is zeus batman is hades aquaman
is neptune and they kind of fit into the
pantheon of gods of a lot of different
cultures superman is as much of a moses
figure as he is a christ figure you know
it's coming from another world you know
having all this power
and really saving lives our redemption
is not going to come from here goes the
myth instead we'll be saved from the
outside
batman the dark knight detective
gotham's greatest protector his parents
killed before him at an early age he is
the world's greatest detective he's the
world's greatest escape artist and he's
arguably the world's greatest
hand-to-hand combatant
he also has a bazillion dollars
and that's not somebody you want to go
up against
one of the reasons that batman has been
so popular for so long is
his iconography is that of a demon
i mean look at the paintings of medieval
paintings of devils in museums the
battlings the horns
he looks like something that's dark and
evil and his origins are in an act of
murder and yet he's on your side so thor
i mean you're not even hiding that he is
a greek god or roman god whatever he is
he's a mythological god and exodus 23 13
says and in all that i have said to you
be circumspect and make no mention of
the name of other gods nor let it be
heard from your mouth
so we're not supposed to mention these
guys let alone
be reading them as a
superhero the hero that's gonna save the
day
is these false gods
and yet they're
all over
christian homes
movies books posters t-shirts hats
whatever it is days of the week
days with me yeah
i go by the first day a second what i'm
seeing from this text is to protect
yourself god understands the power of
influence of fiction of all these things
so he's just saying protect yourself
protect yourself be on guard
yeah because um these are false gods
that aren't even real
that's maybe why philippians 4 8 is you
know whatever is true right whatever's
noble whatever is a good report explain
uh what you learned about bale and how
so close to the truth
so
you know just to kind of study now the
israelites i'm fascinated because their
experience is so similar to like us like
we can we can
apply some of these things to them
as as what we're experiencing today in
our christian walk and and so i kept
going why why were they constantly
worshiping bale like like what was it
that they were willing to give a draw
yeah and as i started kind of just
diving into a little bit of research the
encyclopedia britannica had this whole
article about baal and and why people
were so fascinated with bale and he was
like the lord the god of the heavens in
the clouds and uh he was the one that
made the sun come out and the rain and
the plants to grow and stuff so that was
in elijah's day
why why it was such a slap in the the
false god's face was god took away the
rain saying it's not him that's doing
this this is me but as as um i kind of
read more and more and more about what
these similarities were that bale had
with god he came down and his arch enemy
was a god named mott which is a snake
god and he ends up fighting the snake
god trying to save the humanity and the
snake god ends up destroying him he dies
he resurrects comes back to life and
it's like you could apply all those
things to god literally and this all
predates jesus
which would make that god look like well
maybe he is the prophesied messiah which
is really interesting but you know it's
like who knows that what was gonna
happen uh satan was standing there in
the garden of eden when the prophecy was
gonna come that a you know baby was
gonna come and and crush the head of the
snake and you know so so it's like he's
just kind of
um you know
told another culture that story but
leaves out all of the important parts
and that's really about morality that's
the difference is it's like you know if
you've got this god that that fights for
you but it really has nothing to do with
your sinful self that's not what jesus
was about jesus name was jesus because
he was to save his people from their sin
so morality has always been what god is
wanting for us not just salvation from
whatever
oppression at the time and god clearly
told the people
don't worship baal um you know he said
you know i will destroy anybody that's
that's you know that's interesting as a
oh go ahead no i was just gonna say it
really speaks to the point that you're
bringing out and that is
was it effective it was effective you
know how many times did they fall into
that you get to the time of elijah and
he's crying out to god he's like i'm the
only one left like everybody else is
worshiping bale and jezebel has 450
prophets of baal and
they hunted him down to kill the last
one to kill him
you know because he's because he was
like look no do no rain god is serious
like do not worship this mean
i think that's why the ten commandments
the very first one is you know god is
the only one that is worthy of our
worship
and and satan knows that we we were
designed to worship and so he's just
bending and twisting and and you know we
get caught up in all these stories and
and and it is a form of worship if you
if you are reading these comic books and
not reading your bible that's your god
if you're wearing the t-shirt yeah i
mean where's your t-shirt of jesus we
got lots of t-shirts with jesus on
speaking of jesus
if you want to wear a t-shirt that
promotes who you actually follow you can
go to
lightware.com stop shop sorry dog shop
wait let me say that again you can go to
lightware.shop
that's right and you can shop for
awesome jesus i think it's interesting
you're talking about the word morality
and i'm like these books have a moral in
them they're teaching you a moral which
is morality where's the moral
in
these comic books where
maybe okay maybe the superhero sees he's
looking down in the city alleyway and
there's you know two guys roughing up a
chick and they're about to take
advantage of her and he comes down he
saves her right that sounds like a good
moral but then he like
kills the bad guys and makes out with
the girl and she's oh my hero or
whatever
that's not the character of jesus that's
not what he came to do so it's it's
always that's the thing people are
always like no you missed it it's about
brotherhood it's about redemption all
these things yeah players and morality
of course they're gonna have those in
there you're not even gonna watch it
because it's like if some movie or
whatever is just pure evil
there's gonna be some people that watch
it but for the most part people aren't
gonna watch it or their parents aren't
gonna let them but if it's wrapped up in
this
pretty package and this underlying theme
in there i think there's also a danger
in um let's just say hypothetically that
that character was being branded as some
sort of jesus allegory like superman but
now he's like starting to come out as
gay and he's bisexual and he's got like
you know there's always these story
lines where where they're really
tinkering with that well what does that
do with your picture of jesus if that's
what you're you're attributing those
things to and then why are they trying
to change their original story instead
of creating a whole new character
yeah exactly why not have you know a
superhero that that has those attributes
i don't know it's because that character
is already influential exactly so they
change it
yeah that's blowing me away because i
keep talking about that i keep talking
about how you know
from time to time i might look and be
like i wonder this show looks like it
might be wholesome or whatever and it's
like after by
season episode one
is like oh that was it wasn't so bad and
then episode two it's like somebody's
coming out of the closet somebody
spreading witchcraft or whatever they're
trying to suck you in and get you
attached to the characters and oh i
gotta see season two or whatever
and that's what's happening with
arthur
30 years
it seemed like a good cartoon now the
gay wedding
sesame street i mean it's a bunch of
monsters but then they have uh the guy
in the
tuxedo dress come on there blue's clues
i mean that's been out since i was at
least in high school
by the opponent and that's probably
always based on magic but
i mean yeah sesame street just for a
long time i'm like look there's a
vampire yeah vampire monsters
undead you know
yeah really all of them are monsters and
you're not just saying that it really is
cookie monster elmo will say i'm just a
friendly little monster whatever i
actually seen a commercial where it
showed like a first-person view
going through a house
and it was like kind of this eerie music
and then it's like there's a monster in
your house it's like don't worry he just
wants to play and it was a video game
for sesame street so just kind of hit a
little bit back on what we were covering
a bit ago a little bit of church history
talking about idolatry
it was the church of thyatira
that god was like look
there there's a problem here and it had
to do with the idolatry so i just want
to read this out of revelation chapter
2.
um
it says
nevertheless i have a few things against
you because you allow that woman jezebel
right so remember jezebel jezebel was
queen in israel when elijah was you know
thought he was the only one in the
prophet in israel and they were
apostasizing and worshipping baal
who calls herself a prophetess to teach
and seduce my servants to commit sexual
immorality and to eat things sacrificed
to idols
okay
that was so if you look at if you look
at the book of revelation and you look
at time periods in history this is the
time period that starts what we call
the dark or the middle ages and what
started coming into the christian church
paganism lots of paganism lots of
idolatry yeah so
even that is a subtle like nod using an
old testament character and story and
god is saying like look you know this
story the problem was idolatry and guess
what it's coming around today in the
christian church so it shouldn't
surprise us that we're
seeing those things i think that's when
thor was introduced in the dark ages
wasn't it isn't isn't i don't know the
wow the god that he's modeled after i
can't remember
what does jezebel mean
i don't remember what it means does that
l concept apply to her name too
might but you do have
it can be tricky there because
lots of
neighboring countries can have
similarities in languages
um
so jezebel is from
zidane
she's not an israelite
she's from another country and so she's
a married and princess to the israelite
nation which would explain why she's
more prone to worship bale
um it's this the the twist
at least in the bible as i read it is
kind of amusing is when elijah's running
out of food
and god is like okay you know the
river's dried up the creek's dried up
there's no more food no more ravens or
whatever go to zeiden
the area that she was from she won't
look for you and go to the widow
and so you hear you have these two
women that's even better i didn't know
that she actually went to her hometown
you actually didn't need to read the
newsletter i put that article on the
newsletter we sent out
okay yeah this whole little cool story
is when i say i was like wow god is
really cool and what it showed what it
spoke to me this kind of a side tangent
is that god has his people everywhere oh
yeah you know and so he sent him to a
faithful woman in a in a pagan land
and if you but think about what jesus
said too um
when jesus was doing his ministry
he said
um
i'm trying to think of the exact quote
but that
you know
tyre and sidon would um
condemn
basically
um
the land of israel for the the works
that had been done in there and not
not you know entire insider
basically giving an odd and saying look
these people
they there's some hearts there that can
be turned toward me and if they've seen
what you've seen they've turned
and you guys are rejecting me so so we
have a newsletter how do people sign up
for that
you know that's the one we sent out in
the mail once a year so if you uh send
us your email we kind of have an
automated system it'll kick you an email
and say hey fill out a couple extra
details you know if you give us your
mailing address we'll send that out to
you little light studios order something
we got it that's right awesome
so
i like that you included that bible
story because that was interesting
because i i want to end on you know
what the bible says about these things
do we
i we're not ever going to tell anybody
what to do we're not going to say
so right now we just want you to go out
and burn all your dvds that's not our
position to do that we're just
presenting information we hope that you
desire to
do god's will and ask for the holy
spirit to guide you and direct you and
what you should do
but i mean it's clear that these
heroes are false gods and god says don't
even mention their names
as well as psalm 101 3 says i will set
nothing wicked before my eyes i hate the
work of those who fall away it shall not
cling to me
god cares about what we put in front of
our eyes fiction or not
romans 1 32 says
who knowing the judgment of god that
they which commit such things are worthy
of death not only do the same but have
pleasure in them that do them
so when we're sitting here watching some
gamer
do head shots or we're watching some
movie where they're killing people and
committing adultery and we're like yeah
we're
vicariously enjoying that and being
entertained by it we're just as guilty
as the one who's doing those things
matthew 5
27-28 says you have heard that it was
said to those of old you shall not
commit adultery but i say to you that
whoever looks at a woman to lust for her
has already committed adultery with her
in his heart
so jesus is saying that sin starts in
the mind you know you're
if you hate your brother that's the same
as murder if you're looking at that
woman with lust that's the same as
committing adultery so when you're
watching a movie
and it's
doing things that are making you lust or
or you're watching that violent act
it's just as bad as doing those sins
yourself i i think that that this is
where a lot of people i've had this
conversation with lots of people over
the years
where they'll say
look there's no movie that's going to
dislodge my understanding of god i'm
sorry like if i watch this movie i'm not
all of a sudden going to reject god
right but those verses that you just
read really put painted into perspective
of like
i mean how can you take pleasure in
something that's slamming god right um i
recently had a conversation with
somebody that that um was talking about
watching full metal alchemist the the
anime
and he was like i know i know it's not
right and everything like this and i
said what's the end of full metal
alchemist well they kill god
but why would you invest time into
something like that i think if you just
swap the name out god you're married
somebody was writing a whole series
about killing your wife would you watch
it no you know it's like killing your
kids no you wouldn't watch it if you
were playing fortnite and those were all
your family members you would not be
running around shooting them and dancing
over their dead bodies yeah but
you see the way people play it i mean
you just watch these these twitch people
that are sitting there for hours playing
these video games and they're like yeah
yeah yeah blow his head off
that's putting a spirit inside of you
that you don't care about those people
and i you know i i think it's much more
impactful than people think it is
because
if you are disgusted with sin
you would not put it before your eyes
right you make a really good point and i
think those changes don't
necessarily i think a lot of times i
mean i'll give people credit yeah on a
one-off probably not but if it's a
concentrated diet
one has to question you know i'll use
the analogy of food just because it's an
easy target if i have an apple and i
have an ice cream
you know
what are you going to choose to eat in
in that single moment which one is is
the ice cream probably going to make you
ill and have health problems
probably not not on a one-off right but
if you're choosing the ice cream over
the apple every single day good analogy
those are going to add up to health
problems later on down the line right
just like people that they eat
just a steady diet at mcdonald's it
takes a toll even if you eat the apple
and the ice cream you know what i mean
like i put bananas on my ice cream that
still is not going to like
yeah
it's it's a hot fudge sundae there's a
banana in there yeah
you you need to see sin as a sinful
thing
right
yeah so yeah these yeah these are great
techs and and i know this is probably
going to come up because we always get
this
and that is
what about this story or that story what
about pilgrim's progress or what about
c.s lewis or what about lord of the
rings you know what
why don't you tune in to the post show
and we'll talk a little bit about that
here's the patreon post show there you
go awesome so after this go to patreon
and if you're a patreon you'll be able
to see that i love that very powerful
illustration about the
apple and the ice cream because it is
it's a slow thing it's just like
smoking weed or drinking beer whatever
like yeah i drink beer on the weekends
or whatever and it doesn't do anything
to me and then
you know 10 years of doing that later
your brain cells are being killed and
you have a drunk driving accident you
know it's like
sin always looks fun in the beginning
fornication oh man it's great all these
things and now you got a baby and we're
going to are we gonna board are we gonna
get married what and all these decisions
it's usually not gonna happen the first
few times yeah i know this is totally
off topic but i have to throw this out
there real quick before you before you
say this thought i'm fascinated by this
johnny depp uh um
yeah yeah and and this one thing that
they brought out was like
mr johnny depp have you done drugs
and he's like of course i am right you
know and it's like it's like oh now look
at how they're painting that is such a
bad thing
but then it's glorified in the media all
the time they put it in how many movies
and like everybody promotes this is this
is a fun thing except for
it will turn on you at some point and
and you see the dark side they should
have said did you watch the movie blow
yeah did you like it yeah all right
you like the movie that glorified the
cocaine at it okay
well i had to do those drugs
so a little bit of personal hair
you ever you ever been a pop drinker no
have you um not really not really i
don't know for sure
have you yeah okay me too yeah i used to
suck mountain dew down like it was water
um
so i stopped at some point i don't do
that anymore okay
and i'm not here to ask you guys what
your personal habits are i mean that's
your business but i stopped at some
point i don't i don't drink mountain dew
and
there's been a time or
two in the last i don't know
a few years because it's been a long
time since i quit
you try
something you try a sip of something or
you're at somebody's house or a
party or get together or something
it doesn't taste the same you know you
get away from it
and your taste
changes
you know i can't deny that there's
things that i've watched or done and
enjoyed them you know in that moment i
can't deny that i enjoy it just like
eating the ice cream and apple they both
taste good i mean i wouldn't deny that
they taste good
and so but it's like
there's damage done over time but if you
separate yourself from that just like if
you don't listen to music for a while
you start to realize the effect that
music has on you it's the same with this
if you
back off from violent video games or
sexualized tvs and movies or whatever
and then you go back to something like
that or you see it again it's shocking
yeah it has it has a different effect on
the resources
yeah you start to be like oh you know
just like the sip of mountain dew it's
like oh that that actually tastes bad
like it just tastes like a bunch of
chemicals and it doesn't even taste good
even though it has all this sugar in it
it's the same kind of thing i think with
our media choices whether it's a book or
a tv show or a movie or an internet site
or a game or what have you
it has the same it's the same kind of
thing so
you can think about it in those terms
i think it helps yeah
so we looked at how the
the comic books are making these heroes
their false gods or they're just
blatantly satan what are they what are
the villains i mean thanos he's walking
on water in this scene he's sitting on a
throne and a ship called the sanctuary
he's coming to earth to destroy half of
humanity that's a description of jesus
he's coming to separate the sheep and
the goats and
they call him father he calls his
followers children and he's just like on
and on deadpool making a mockery of
jesus christ on a poster and yet you
will he's not getting
sued by chris by christians yet
the satanic church is suing sabrina for
using uh their statue in a wrong light
the joker wearing a crown of thorns with
his arms outstretched
so i mean if we're watching things we're
being entertained by things like that
verse said in romans that's
making satan or pagan gods look like
heroes and we're making the enemy have
all these attributes of god
should we really be watching those
things you know we have documentaries on
this subject magic kingdom talks about
disney how it's always about breaking
the rules following your heart we got
replacement gods that goes way in depth
about the history of the comic heroes
where they come from a whole documentary
just on the black panther called the
black panther deception
and anime man that's the newest one that
so many people are getting into when i
watched anime as a
gothic teenager i had to buy the vhs's
on ebay i mean you couldn't go to
walmart like you can now
and buy a t-shirt and a whole box set
but this is something that a lot of
young people are engaged in right now
and i'm telling you for a culture that
has less than one percent of
christianity
there is a lot of biblical themes in it
and it's always inverted god is always
the enemy to the point where now
the seven deadly sins is a show based on
heroes that are called the seven deadly
sins personifications of each sin and
the bad guys are the ten commandments
we've gone that far where now we're
fighting against the ten commandments
yeah i think
you know to be to be fair to our
audience or listeners or watchers or
somebody who may come across this video
it's good to also bring out the point
that maybe that's not you you're not
into these specific things
but it's something else you know maybe
it is video games maybe it is how much
time you spend on an internet site or or
novel candy crush or whatever it is
yeah novels
and maybe you're looking at it like well
it's not going to change my opinion
about god
but
i would say this
all the moments that we spend with these
things
are investments
right their investments into that thing
and if they're taking you away from god
that's an investment that takes you away
from god or an investment that maybe
it denies god in some fashion or it
teaches you something contrary to what
the bible teaches
the more investments you make
in that
side
the more detrimental it is to your
spiritual health and to your
relationship with christ
and
you know we that's why we like to use
the illustration of
think of it as a significant other you
know if you're old enough to have that
kind of relationship or your mom or your
dad your mom or your dad yeah do you
enjoy spending time with that person or
do you just hate spending time with that
person
and we're not talking about a an abusive
relationship we're talking about a
normal healthy relationship
what do i want to spend my time doing do
i want to spend my time with my wife and
my kids or i would just
ignore them it's the same with god that
relationship does not grow it does not
increase it does not get better
if you don't invest your time
in it
and at the end of the day
we know from scripture that jesus will
say to a group of people
who thought they were doing the right
things
depart from me i never knew you yeah if
you don't know somebody you definitely
don't have a relationship with them
and we're just
here to
help people not be in that category we
don't want you to be in me jesus says i
don't know you category because that to
me i think of all the words i could ever
hear at the end of my life you know as
god as the judge
that's got to be the most terrifying
you know
you know i don't know you especially
when people are like didn't i cast out
demons didn't i do these these things in
your name didn't i wasn't those aren't
that's not the class of people that
didn't know
god yeah they they didn't do his will
yeah
yeah we hope you're blessed by this
video if you learn something new or if
you know somebody that might be
struggling with these things share it
with them say you know i watch this
video what do you think about it put the
ball on their course see what their
opinion is
and uh it might just help them open
their eyes so share this video we also
have
clothes we got shirts on lightwear.shop
that helps support our ministry it helps
you to share and wear your witness it's
a icebreaker for opening up the
conversation about the gospel and you
can follow us on all social media and we
also have the international platform as
well so we hope you were blessed by this
please give us a simple thumbs up it's
free it's easy and it helps this video
get out to many other people and share
it and click subscribe and we'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
you